hey youtubers is Charlie this is gonna
be my Walking Dead midseason finale
video so much craziness so much stuff to
set up for the back half of the season
so try to cover everything just careful
for spoilers if you haven't seen it yet
there is a new round of the walking dead
giveaway going on now all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on this video be sure to click
that Bell to enable alerts so you don't
miss anything during the break but let's
do it MVP the episode either Darrell who
went full negan depending on which way
you go on it or Spencer who just totally
went for that brass ring fell a little
bit short did not quite stick the
landing but it's okay I'm sure Rosita
found somebody else to have dinner with
that night but that was kind of funny
like she holds him in such contempt but
she's still relented and was like yeah
okay I'll have dinner with you whatever
but the whole thing about this episode
is that they're finally coming to the
conclusion that they need to come
together they even teased it in the
promo we need to work together to do
something about negan so that is all
march to war that's like the next volume
in the comics so that's what they're
going to work through through the back
half of the season and then they'll
start teasing all-out war and I know
everybody's asking who do those boots
belong to there's a new person that they
cast I'll talk about that as I work
through top 10 WTF but here we go number
10 Maggie vs. Gregory Maggie for
president of hilltop you can see exactly
what they're setting up here the thing
about Maggie is that you know because of
what this episode was implying how
they're going to start fighting back how
they want to be hopeful Maggie is
effectively invincible or I should say
untouchable is a better word inside the
writers room so if you're making a
shortlist of characters that will
probably never die at least any time
soon Maggie is close if not at the top
of that list along with like Rick
Michonne Daryl baby Judith so give the
pregnant lady the Apple they really want
to make regular seem like a super
[ __ ] but he's a comic book character
he has a very specific comic book arc so
you could totally read ahead and find
out where that goes because it's going
to be right out of the comics so if you
actually do want to read ahead in the
comics during the break March the war
starts out with Walking Dead vol 109 it
goes through 114 and then right after
that is all-out war part 1
number nine comic book negan shaves
himself just like Rick in Rick's house
very different scene from when Rick
shaped his beard back at the beginning
of season six remember how big his beard
hecarim he was more beard than man at
that point but now the beard is totally
coming back so it's so hilarious that
negan is losing the beard beard equals
power in the walking dead so Rick's
beard is like slowly growing back out
just as Nikken shave says so it's a bit
of a hat tip to the shift in power on
the show now now that Rick's like come
to this realization oh yeah we can fight
negan and Nikas just getting too
comfortable in the suburbs but the whole
thing with negan's beard has been talked
about it has something to do with
Jeffrey Dean Morgan being on The Good
Wife and having to have a beard on that
TV show when he came on to Walking Dead
so he had to keep the beard for a little
while but comic book negan has never had
a beard so now he's just closer to comic
book negan the really funny part about
this isn't so much negan though is this
the look on Judas face just when you
consider that we're on like maybe our
10th or 12th baby Judith I don't know
how many different kids that they've
recast as Judith just because the
timeline of The Walking Dead moves so
slowly but kids age so fast we're
running into the same problem with Carl
too so I'll talk about Chandler Riggs at
the end of this there's a lot of talk
about him resigning his contract but
that's a completely separate thing so
number 8 Daryl finally busts out with
the help of that note in the key so the
handwriting still looks like Sherry's
handwriting in the room that he busts
into looks like Dwight's like he
suddenly realizes as he's looking around
like you see the TV set that white was
watching TV on you see the peanut butter
the funny thing about the peanut butter
like Daryl just goes to town because
he's so hungry he's been so under fed on
all that dog food they've been giving
him is that Norman Reedus is like I
can't stand peanut butter but they
probably had to shoot a couple versions
of that seat so when they were filming
he probably had to eat a whole bunch of
peanut butter but I loved the way he
acted when he was getting ready to leave
that room like he's sitting in the chair
just kind of waiting for his opportunity
waiting for the conversation to die down
nearby and then sees the little model
with the fortress and the soldiers and
just up in
ends the table just like screw this guy
whoever's room this is so he may not
have actually known that it was Dwight's
but I feel like he felt it was so you
know whoever it was he just wanted to
trash it just a little bit just like
screw you saviors you guys suck so
number seven
negan versus Rick's kitchen make some
spaghetti even sets a place for Lucille
because who knows where Rick is well I'm
not waiting anymore past the rolls I
love how passive negan was in this
episode usually he's up in everyone's
faces but in this episode he was just
trying to enjoy all the air conditioning
the nice kitchen the food just chill out
put his feet up so it really took the
entire episode for him to get pissed and
that was really only when Rosita took a
shot at him but the whole idea with
scenes like this is that he's meant to
feel like the unwelcome house guest that
won't get out like dude this is our
house you need to get out of here so
they just really wanted to beat you in
the face with that now is the time to
kick the savior's out of our house
talking about the safe zone people maybe
we can agree on this but did you guys
feel like with the extra emphasis on
Olivia in the episode like that
extra-long scene with Tara that almost
seemed kind of pointless like she was
getting ready to throw herself on a
spear for negan to save Judith or just
keep everything in Rick's house from
spiraling out of control because she
felt like it was her duty to protect
Carl and Judith that she was going to
die at the end of the episode no matter
what happened like any time they focused
this much on a c-list character like
Olivia you know they're getting ready
for some big twist they're gonna pull
the rug out from under you in some way
and just because this is the mid-season
finale and they hadn't killed someone in
a while you almost sense that she's
going to be one of the people to die
Spencer could have gone either way he
was the more fun kill like I was really
happy they got rid of him so number six
Rick and Aaron make their way to the
houseboat to look for supplies so
there's just all kinds of weapons there
bullet holes and everything they're a
bunch of Walker traps so the whole point
of this scene isn't so much that they're
getting supplies it's just an
opportunity for Aaron to double down on
Rick's cause like he's like dude I'm
totally in on what we're doing helping
people
even if it means that
have to bargain with the savior's I
understand what you're doing I'm with
you so the last couple of episodes
there's been this thing with people
questioning Rick's leadership people
wondering what was going on like even
Karl went to kill negan because he
wasn't satisfied with how far Rick was
going so this Aaron scene was really
like the answer to that look there are
people that believe in what you're doing
that understand what's going on the
situation we're in so they did have like
a fun bait and switch where Aaron goes
under and you're like oh my god did they
just kill Aaron then he pops back up I'm
fine I'm fine that was kind of a
metaphor for the episode where like
everybody starts drowning but then by
the end they're all like okay we're fine
we're gonna fight negan now so number 5
they make it onto the boat and they find
that middle finger on that piece of
paper that was so hilarious you win but
you lose I feel like the reason they
included that was just so that they
could have that moment later with the
Savior's picking it up and going what
the hell does this mean you win but you
lose like that was meant to be more of a
metaphor for the Savior's and then you
know number four who the hell are those
boots like somebody's been peeping on
them and there's going to be a lot of
debate about this during the break
because there are a couple big
characters that need to be introduced
and one of those is the whispers like
those are big characters so there's a
female character that leads them called
alpha there's also another female
characters that leads another small
group that's near Alexandria called
Magne so I think that this character is
probably magnet just because she debuts
before alpha and the whisperers do in
the comics so the thing about this is
that they're really just teasing that
somebody's watching them you don't know
if they're good you don't know if
they're bad but there's a character that
they're casting called Bri on and they
haven't announced which actress is
playing her yet so that's probably who
this character is and here's the thing
about that the name is not somebody from
the comics but she's supposed to be a
tough female character who is the leader
of another group so they're basically
casting either Magne or somebody from
the whispers or somebody from a totally
new group but I do think that it's from
one of the comic book groups in the name
they're using that Breann name is just
fake to misdirect people so even though
whispers whisperer
or is something that happens way after
all out war which is something that
we're not even close to yet on the TV
show so you guys can let me know who do
you think these boots belong to magna or
somebody from the whisperers
so we can talk about that during the
break but number three Daryl goes full
negan on fat Jerry I love the way he
performed this scene to Norman Reedus he
was almost like an animal in this moment
just completely lashing out but then
Jesus comes in and he slowly comes back
to consciousness he starts acting like a
human again okay let's get out of here
and he grabs
Rick's revolver so very important for
later but can we just appreciate Norman
Reedus performance in this moment here
he's so great at underperforming Daryl
Daryl isn't somebody that emotes a lot
like he speaks in grunts like that later
moment where he almost breaks down
crying and hugs Rick it's very
underperformed compared to somebody like
Jeffrey Dean Morgan doing his negan who
just pontificates and just goes on and
on and just talks his head off so Daryl
performances are like the exact opposite
of that so it's really funny to see him
in scenes with characters that won't
shut up but number two [ __ ] goes crazy
at the save zone
negan finally guts Spencer now we know
why they kept him on the show that long
he was one of the most unlikable
characters ever I hated Spencer so I'm
so glad that he's gone the way he was
killed was exactly like the comics like
negan guts him with his knife so they've
actually been pretty good about doing
like the big deaths exactly the way they
happen in the comics there are a couple
characters that they don't have from the
comments like Daryl isn't a comic book
character and they didn't kill Abraham
in the comics that way he got killed a
different way so there are a few minor
changes but for the biggest deaths
they've been happening just like they
did in the comics and I love Eugene's
performance here too just completely
breaks down
negan is taking him because he wants
more bullets and Eugene can make bullets
so even though it sounds like he's going
to go kill him like I'm taking your
bullet maker from you is just because he
wants Eugene to mass produce ammo for
the survivors which is actually very
dangerous considering that everyone
wants to take them on now
so a lot of people were blaming Rosita
for the deaths in this episode because
she took a shot at negan but Spencer was
killed before she ever took a shot so
that had nothing to do with Rosita you
could blame Olivia on Rosita but the
thing about that is that she was a
relatively minor character I don't feel
like they really needed her on the show
so what they're doing here is they're
giving you like the gore like oh my god
a couple people died that have been with
us for a while but they're holding off
on really big a-list character deaths
for season finale so if you want to
speculate on like really huge deaths
then just save that for whatever the
season finale is going to be in episode
16 but it was a really great scene the
way they played it in the episode itself
wasn't that crazy like there was just a
lot of storylines that they had to wrap
up so that they could get to this moment
at the end where they all decide hey
we're gonna fight negan but number one
was Rick getting the revolver back
everybody meeting at Hilltop better
watch out now the sheriff's back in town
so the only thing that would have made
this scene better is if Rick had taken
his hat off of Carl's head and put it
back on but that might have been too
on-the-nose you guys can let me know
like what did you think about that
moment when Rick took his revolver back
check the bullets and just holstered it
like BAM time to get to business
the ending was the ending that they had
needed to get to for a while I feel like
one of the big complaints for the last
couple of episodes is that things has
gotten so depressing but you can see why
they wanted to do that they wanted to
have this big payoff moment where they
all decide you know based on Michonne
speech with Rick hey we're still
standing here we can fight back
in Rick's like I realized that now they
just wanted to take their time getting
to that moment dragging the characters
through the mud making negan feel like
the unwelcome house guest so now I feel
like the show can be a little bit more
fun because it can be all about them
making their plans marshalling forces to
fight negan so now we actually have some
momentum heading into the season finale
when the show comes back but you guys
can let me know like what did you think
of this first half of the season in The
Walking Dead there were a couple really
crazy moments but it was really just all
about the reign of negan dragging
everybody through the mud the breaking
of Rick Grimes so whatever your
complaints were about the first half of
the season I feel like it's going to be
completely different in the back half
they tend to do that with the Walking
Dead every eight episodes they try to
change what the show is so when it comes
back it should feel like a totally
different experience which i think is a
really good thing what's going to happen
next is I'll do Westworld season two
predictions then I'll do a Walking Dead
trailer video for the rest of the season
so I'll try to get those videos up as
fast as possible while you guys wait for
that to post you can click here for my
Walking Dead playlist and you can click
here to rewatch the Fast 8 trailer thank
you so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight
you